hier sind wir mit silly allerdings silly
ist nicht ganz komplett weil eigentlich
habt ihr von frauen wichtig die heißt
anna anna loos und anna loos anna loos
hat noch ein kleines hobby nebenbei sie
ist schauspielerin und gerade im film
ein kleines gut bezahltes hobby haben
wir das mal erlaubt damit sie gute laune
kriegt ok habt jetzt erlaubt sonst hätte
der ist nicht erlaubt aber morgen sie
kriegt sie frei morgen aber nicht von
euch sondern von denen wir in den maria
okay okay also alles ist gesichert wie
macht das jetzt wenn proben ohne sie
oder probten wir machen wo wir morgen
machte prof wie ist es stoppt meisten
proben sind wir heute ja ich glaube auch
also sie zumindest aus sie kenne den
plan jetzt nicht aus wenn ich habe nicht
auswendig gelernt aber wir haben morgen
früh an mit frühstücksfernsehen sat 1
und danach kommen wir zur probe und dann
haben wir 20 stunden tagten und dann
generalprobe hat man ja nicht weiche
knie überhaupt nicht wir machen das
nicht erst seit gestern achtet so aus
danke also wir sind schon gespannt und
das wird garantiert morgens ein bisschen
aufregung hinzu kommen das ist auch gut
so sonst könnte man aufhören damit mit
dem job aber wir sind froh dass wir
dabei sein können weil es ist einfach
eine plattform für deutschsprachige rock
pop musik die es so im deutschen
fernsehen eigentlich nicht mehr gibt
woran liegt das das liegt an den
redakteuren denke ich mal also an den
benz liegt es nicht es gibt genügend
angebote und es gibt genügend gute musik
in deutschland gut das sieht man ja an
dem an dem an dem spektrum massenhaft
vorhanden ist
es ist genug material vorhanden macht
mehr deutsche musik im fernsehen
freilich ist es so dass immer dass
dieses wort format genutzt wird neuer
seit einigen jahren und die deutsche
fernsehen glaubt offensichtlich vor
allem der öffentlich-rechtliche glaubt
offensichtlich nicht mehr an dieses
format also reine musik sendung zu
machen aber stephan hat das vor sechs
jahren glaube ich installiert und ein
hammer wie sich das entwickelt hat und
man sieht auch an der reaktion der leute
an dem feedback was dass sie das auch
wollen und brauchen und dass er außerdem
sagen wir hier im ganz besondere note
die die deutsche musikszene bedient wenn
ich auch hervorragend
jetzt
gibt es aber doch so schöne musik
sendung wie die volkstümliche hitparade
und ich frühlingsfest der volksmusik und
wie es alles also deutschsprachige musik
komfort aber irgendwie ganz komisch also
alles was pop und rockmusik komisch ist
wird komischerweise ausgeblendet als
wäre das nicht existent ich meine im
internationalen sinne findet dass hier
und da stadt aber deutsch nun gerade
sehr sehr wenig seit vielen jahren wobei
im radio kommt er immer mehr na ja also
ich habe gerade wiederum gehört dass die
sendeminuten für deutschsprachige songs
im radio so in alle zwei stunden haben
die klubs vier minuten für den deutschen
titel oder also das ist nicht sehr viel
also als wenn das letzte steigerung
jetzt muss man sich fragen was gab es da
vorher aber als ich heute her gefahren
bin lief im radio alles rot von uns also
schon mal super das gibt doch was ist
irgendwie das ist klasse also wenn man
seinen eigenen song im radio hört ist
immer was ganz besonderes ok ich wünsche
euch dass ihr ja noch möglichst oft
euren eigenen song im radio hört und so
und dafür lieber youtuber wie immer wenn
ihr silly sensationell findet votet für
sie auch hier auf youtube sums up für
dieses video favorisiertes guckte so oft
wie ihr könnt weil dann kommen die drei
nach oben auch auf youtube ja wir haben
ein youtube channel sales channel auf
youtube ja da gibt es ganz viele videos
von uns denen müssen wir direkt mal
verlinken dann gehen nämlich direkte
views hoch und ja was wünscht ihr euch
von den zuschauern morgen ja wir
wünschen uns auf jeden fall dass wir uns
so weit wie möglich nach vorne punkte
egal wo wir landen wir sind in jedem
fall gewinner weil wir unseren silly
virus verbreiten können